what do you think is the biggest lie
that feminism tells
women I guess I mean it's about defining
what they're telling them that they can
do everything a man can do mhm or that
they I number one I'd say is that they
don't need
men let's keep it real you definitely
need men and they're they're just as
strong as
men this will probably be controversial
for me to say but if men want to enslave
women they could do
it I mean physically stronger in every
way if they wanted to like obviously
that's a stupid thing to do I don't
support that but like men do run the
situation so the fact that think that
women don't mean man it's like that
apartment example what would you do if
you didn't have a man oh you get an
apartment yeah but not if you didn't
build it